pentagon author ballgames
television journal of the implementation
of the hour
structural you every monday wednesday
and friday
presentation of the laundry withdraw
what happened
later on
launching the world's most armored
walked
and whatnot
distinguished companion to the world on
a launching
good evening
this is david rocks
may i introduce our co-editors
for this edition of the launching cross
kore
mister william bradford kiwi
and mister henry hatfield
our distinguished guest for this evening
is the honorable john sherman cooper
senator-elect from kentucky
so difficult for a very happy to welcome
you caught a scope this evening
i'd like to begin by asking you because
of your experience in the u_n_
whether you think there's any chance for
true security in now
because of the moment
immediately
uh... i i do not think so
which is always full
uh... i i don't look forward to in the
immediate troops and frankly i have
never felt that the
i think for action in the
recent days
resolution the indian resolution is
for them and getting up forms
genomic authors say that he thinks he
has a clear a definite solution of the
problem
mistaken view of that that uh... general
eisenhower or consult with them now
forceps
question for general eisenhower
pat i would guess that
he would be withdrawn
to find out what his plan is
i think it would be indefinitely
for what steps do you think can be taken
to put their pressure on the chinese
communist of one approves
knowledge that think of this
grand questions as part of the
of the uh... larger
difficulties between russia
the rest of the world
and with that
did you start out but knowing it
it's a difficult problem of a long
problem
because we have the
real force there
uh... i believe that
we've got to have
the strength in korea
which will give the greatest
influence to our
well a lot of some of the snaps wouldn't
be so i think the the viewpoint
not knowing the sales but the
military dispositions are there
i'm not certain
how much should be added but
before the convention russia mercure
primarily that
that they cannot win the famous adjust
the position
and career that i think we've got to
have the string further
uh... certainly favor the
the proposition in general eisenhower
that his quickly as we can
we build up the streets of south korea
very strongly that
every bit of influence that we can bring
to bear upon
the other members of the united nations
should be brought
to get from them
military strength added economic
strength lozad and proper aller
yours of course tonight thinking about
the
u_s_s_
helen out in the pacific and all of this
uh... meetings going on out there
uh... nasa first of all
uh... why do you think all of these
cabinet members of the most out to see
general eisenhower and canada board
uh... bag helicopter
with mrs
it's a good operation
well you know the illusion that had a
little melodramatic to you uh... one oh
i don't think so i swear correct
the the first place
everybody at
presented in korea
he's he's just ten days dot whatever
information that he could get their and
i think it's
with his
experience it
that he has got
new information and
much clearer beautiful
mister those has been in washington
conferring with the state before
me has there been
and now they meet
together and
there's a chance to
bring together
those but different viewpoints
but we'll be right back
i think that probably the best
opportunity he'll have
until the takes the oath of office
and perhaps for a long time after that
as many of his advisers together and
have the chance
tuned confer
without interruption
well is it wrong about other things
besides career there
well here i don't think
one of the things that make you
intersting that beers and here is
uh... you republican who's just uh...
been elected to the senate down in
kentucky
and i believe that you are the only
republican
that was elected to the senate
and the state
that did not vote for eisenhower
is that correct c
but that is true but
the just like a few votes of voting for
azamara out of
about a million votes
mister stevenson shed constructive only
seven hundred votes and yet uh... no
stevenson kidded state you were elected
to the senate
that back what what was your majority
owner training and for us in
now add let me ask you this year
plan where you elected to the senate
and what did you have the general
eisenhower didn't have been that in
kentucky
i'd like to make it for him
i probably wouldn't be here on this
program
it's at all as a diabetic and
so that they want why do you think he
has
it made the change
but why do you think you you ran ahead
ticketed legacy
is because you are well known owner and
i have elections third race are made for
the senate and six years
and of course
they do normally
i would hope so
i was on the senate two years and
then do they approved of my records
there
you are not always on the ground
notified all the time generalize matter
came into
interviewing day
we're getting money back to you the care
kentucky put for about eight or nine
months
i was on the ground there would be
making fight
right now other than the republican
party is a strong in kentucky and these
are the growing party there
no signs of
unquestionable always ask his and you
are eight republican from kentucky
actually
miss kentucky has a
rather strong republican party out of
about
a million registered voters
we have a registered voter about two
hundred and twenty five
thousand registered republicans
we cashed in
consistent with the republican vote
since nineteen hundred we've had five
out of the fifteen brothers
which are about the first republican has
been sent to congress
live from talking twenty five years when
she won nineteen forty six the
ninety minutes or so if there was a
first
one who'd been elected the senate
for the senate and twenty eight
savvier system coming from born in a
huge insurance from a state that has a
strong republican party what do you
think of the republican party's chances
making a solid the reluctant party
system itself
my status
set of border state and and and then
that uh... category you could class west
virginia
oklahoma
even tennessee
i think that
all of those states those four states
have
possibilities
to become republican states are at least
two have been a position where they
could
republican majorities
a much more often
and i think there that's a problem
good morning is from outside from the
in kentucky
and these border states
and then
the parties in the states
watching their leadership
having good programs and uh...
remembers to develop
their own party i think the situation in
the south is different
uh... while higher status not typically
southern state politically
rests on the same problem
where the problem of
not having
local and state administrations which
give your continuity
learning can be done south instream
take advantage of the azamara pickford
to take him to the leadership
some of the democrats who
for generalizing undertaken and
leadership even more in
importantly
came under his banners here's a national
holiday although you're
republican you have been serving as a
delegate idea of the truman
administrators are serviceability right
women and girls
your experience and i'd like to ask you
some questions about the u_n_ phrase do
you think the in the united nations says
no mister that's not the succession the
terms of
people talk
i think it's had a successful
i think it's great successes of his
it's been a national passion with which
as hell together
the nation's where members of the
satellite nations and russia
and kept them pretty generally reform
fence posts as against rs russian
domination and aggression or has as one
of those cheap affect being black is a
sounding board for rashi in propaganda
against the united states
who has just given russia
a forum
is also given united states
smaller countries whistle
oil it was given
and the other nations of the world there
at least the representatives of their
chance to
uh... scene
the russians to hear them and our allies
their propaganda i think that's been a
definite valley
grocer our viewers i'm sure would like
to have
reviews on about the republican party is
likely to do on domestic issues
on january the twentieth
first of all so you believe that the
republican party will reduce taxes
i think it will be
take the steps which will lead to
revenge in texas
i think production taxes depends of
walpole would have mentioned
general
will show you where you think that the
uh... that the republican party will
attempt to repeal any of the
so-called social legislation
that's been built up by the new unfair
deals
uh... detailed
there may be
specific laws will be repealed
in general
i think the general programs of social
security
weijin are lol
some labor legislation
well i don't know if you program it will
be maintained but they will be examined
and analyzed
when you come from a state that has
and a personable labor vote
you think that they'll be more strikes
under a republican administration then
they have been
i have the you believe that there will
be fewer strings
i think we'll all have already seen some
evidence of that sense
election that some try to bring some
reason i say that is
i believe that one
labels
and capital as well but
i think particularly labor because
delegates generally
understood
evaluate
i think a stroll over advocate but
and the merits always
when they know now that they've got to
do what they say they want to do bargain
collectively
well then you're going to have better
chances for green blockquote
contracts at times have been thank you
for being with us thank you very much
the opinions you heard our speakers
expressed tonight are entirely the wrong
the editorial board for this edition of
the long-term cromer school was mister
william bradford puri
and mister henry has lived
our distinguished guests with very
honorable john sherman cooper
senator-elect from kentucky
under any christmas tree it's the little
packages which intrigue
what can it be we say
and this christmas many hope that uh...
in one like this there'll be a long gene
the world's most alright watch
truly
throughout the world no other name on
the christmas watch means so much as the
name on gene
and the whole world there were a few
watches two week we're launching and
quality and none of such great grandma
among the finest watches of the world
launching alone has one pen world's fair
grand prizes twenty eight gold medal
awards and so many honors for accuracy
now if this christmas you wish to give
the gift of great prestige
alone she
every mon gene watches superlative and
styling superb in finnish
unsurpassed for paypal timekeeping
yet unbelievably you made by and
probably give alone gene watch this
christmas for as little as seventy one
fifty
launching the world's most all earth
watch
the world's most on a christmas gift
premio product
along gene whitmore watch company
since eighteen sixty six
maker of what it's about highest
character
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time
or the launching promise full a
television journals of important issues
of the hour
broadcast on behalf of launching the
world's most honored walks
and whitmore distinguished companion to
the world on a launching
this is david ross speaking for your
regular host prime night reminding you
of the launching and whitmore watches
are sold in service from coast to coast
by more than four thousand leading to
proudly display of its emblem
agency for launching britain all walked
time for the longer
television journal of the important in
terms of the hour
presentation of the laundry withhold
what happened
later on
launching the world's most al-kidwa
and whatnot
distinguished companion to the world on
its own gene
good evening
this is david ross
speaking for your regular host right not
may i introduce our co-editors for this
edition of the launching promise kal
mister william bradford jewelry editor
of the american mercury
mister henry hathaway
contributing editor of newsweek magazine
our distinguished guests for this
evening is the honorable heather farr
o'connor
senator from maryland
saturday i'm very happy to welcome to
the crime has filled this evening
as you're a member of the senate
internal security committee
i'd like to begin by asking you what
your impression is out of this uh...
freeman panel report
that was turned in by the united nations
uh... for the united nations to
secretary general lee
but this has the time
i approve
uh... of the conclusions reached by the
international terrorists
at these three distinguished uh... uh...
attorneys
at have
don
a comprehensive job
i regret that uh...
and it was necessary really too
and in both their age because the
questions presented seem to want to be
very clear in that
that subversive
those individuals of american citizens
rain
uh... who are disposed to work against
the inner city united states we feel
ought never to have been pro-life at the
united nations and the fact that tonight
some fifteen of them are either under
suspension or have been
uh... separated from the uh...
uh... indicates that there was uh...
very much to be done i do think that the
conclusions reached by the in a national
panel uh... are to be approved
well there were several important
conclusions there
the first one important thing to me that
anybody who was an active member of the
communist party could be dismissed
i assume that you agree with that
thoroughly full heart and then there was
another rags and other recommendation
that anybody who had it would make it
that he had been separated in the past
could be suspended until his record was
looked into the light
assume you agree with that but if that
is correct and third not fought quite an
important one in view of the public
uh... confusion on the point is that
that anybody who refused to testifies
on the ground but it might incriminate
him
could be dismissed and should be
dismissed on the ground that he had
as created suspicion of guilt by
diffusion to answer how do you agree
with that final point ideal is better
than i would like to just aditi another
were to work in respect to that
our principal difficulty
uh... in the hearings up until this very
day
act has been
that uh... many of our people of our
citizens labor under a misapprehension
they feel
that having secured a position with a
international organization
uh... are beyond the reach
uh... out that the regularly constituted
get agency of the federal government
enquiring
into their actions
as united nations numbers
optic in relation to the particular work
but uh... prior to their
association with the organization for
outside of the scope of that work
and we'll of course have been deftly of
the police
that uh... the
senate committee has a right
to inquire into their uh... affiliation
with the communist party for example
before their engagement subversive
activities
and wait they declined to answer
on the ground that
to cancer
would tend to incriminate them we feel
that that puts them under suspicion to
such an extent
that they are not
suitable persons her to be in the
secretary at of united nations
researcher clarify disturb it
many american yours and here
feel that your committee is deliberately
harassing united nations
and number one the committee is is the
mccarran committee uh... here's the link
our committee irregularly constituted
subcommittee
i'll be senator he'll hold hearings in
new york and and who are your colleagues
on the committee cert
well senator mccarran of nevada
senator ferguson
of michigan senator watkins senator
jenner senator will smith the former
president of the american
bar associations and refused to
mississippi and myself
now bob
have you found evidence that they are
communist employed american communist
employed by the united nations
definitely
you can eat your position that you you
have a right
to too
investigate
these people and to expose them now we
are right
dead but it did
now are you a a supporter of the united
nations and
yes and i'd like to have digest and
reply on that have been i'm not one
who believes that just because these
uh...
uh... the little problems have arisen
uh... possibly not-so-little but deftly
problems
is the reason for the uh... abolition of
the united nations has such i do not
think that you don't think it'll be
necessary burn down a bone to get rid of
the wreck i do not think so i feel that
the
uh... objectives of the u_n_
now are so important in this critical
period that we should give support to
the u_n_ and we believe
that ultimately al action
will restore the confidence of the
american people which i am regret to say
and we felt was being shaken win
revelations were brought out effective
communist people who had been discharged
from department in washington for either
doubtful loyalty are found in a in the
secretary and for the united nations
do you think there are no win situation
created here senator now my
understanding of this committee report
this panel report
was that uh... leader secretary general
could fire any member of a non communist
nation
guilty of being a communist
but that he said he couldn't fire a
communist of course in the communist
nation now doesn't that create a very
and i was position within the united
nations inka sanden offered is too good
to treat really eat
i feel that the uh... responsibility is
not the indians or the foster family has
not given me because i think he has made
and she had me when i first
to uh... uh... discharged his
responsibilities and at the same time
to retain
the status of the u_n_ as it was
originally conceded is of course
and international organization
if secretary at is not supposed to be
under dictation from any member
uh... the nation
and consequently
uh... he has had to
chart a course
which would be
pad between that uh... that at getting
at recognition to the rights of the
united states for example
as against the the communist country
gotten the very fact that we have
communist nations that members of the
organization
make the organization either ineffective
or effective as a sounding board for
communist exactly so and it is to be
expected
that uh... with the international
organization
including
communist is nations
that of uh... necessity
their representatives
in the secretary at will be sympathizers
at with their uh... particularly over
what you think russia should keep a veto
power over the president has
layout uh... aren't i think of course
that there are rome uh...
reasons on both sides i do not think of
course that
uh... should be carried to the extent
that it has because i
uh... in a way at it demonstrates the
yet uh... fact that uh... russia is not
sincere their in their rad uh... in
their room
uh... efforts to work
achieve the objectives of the u_n_ about
senator
is this a fair statement sir
that our
uh... keeping the united nations in new
york
allowing it to me here
that is a a calculated risk on the part
of a nation isn't he has any calls for
this this one extra consideration i
think as the host
nation
the united states at is uh... within its
rights
in demanding that uh... extra
precautions be taken
to bogart ecc the internal security of
the united states moving on to the
united nations arab leader committee
act
family rather interesting piece of
content
and inside the armed services did it not
that was in the third in the lieutenant
thurman case a very disgraceful one
and uh... and you found that uh... an
officer in the army and
was actually in charge of prisoners
oncology allen but actually he has been
commissioned he still in the army
although with he's under observation by
the uh... at the military authorities
he had been commissioned
at had gone to coach ian had actually
been in joint you fourteen i think
you're going to forty thousand thirty
thousand prisoners of war
and it's now that your committee is
going to take into that situation do you
think that it's being corrected
well i certainly don't think it uh...
ought to be in mind i yet have been a
conference in the uh... bear in the
secretary of the defense of the entire
military stepped in to believe that they
are going to be after the bombing
ngo brought the circumstances rather
remarkable under which he was taken in
yet he refused to answer some
questionable portents yes in the
application for commission
uh... in answer the questions as to
whether he
bizarre has been a member of subversive
organization and he declined to answer
uh... backed on constitutional grounds
well it was nonetheless accepted his
numbers accepted
so that they were cancer years and i
wouldn't want to deliver that recalling
the fact that you are
uh... part of the people over
investigation
now after and looking back in retrospect
only keep forever activities do you
think that that uh... was useful for the
country
i think are useful
yesterday you heard
you're one of those i think that made
the
mister dole i_r_s_ enjoy the clemens
down in mexico are belittling
at least it
uh... he has soldier and therefore the
period since that time
wept what do you think about the
situation as far as crime in our cities
now do you think they did
it's still one that uh... that
through calls for investigation
well i think undoubtedly so i i do not
think uh...
at the u_n_ work of anyone committee in
a limited time
would clear up
the uh... very uh... unfortunate
situation has existed in america in the
large metropolitan areas particularly
and and since you are not to be a member
of the new congress ur
is it your opinion that the new congress
should continue such an investigation i
think there are rare uh... are many
things to be sent in favor of some
periodic jet
whether it would be funny committee set
up ah... as tiki barber
uh... committee was uh... or whether it
would be one that would give just a
tribunal of condition in the country as
well
well thank you very much for being with
us this evening
the opinion through part of our speakers
expressed about our entirely their own
the editorial board for this edition of
the laundry in qana school was
mister william back perjury
and mister henry has lit
our distinguished guests with the
honorable her bizarre o'connor senator
from maryland
the problem of selecting a christmas
gift
prestige was someone near and dear this
most happily styled
with along gene watch
discriminating men and women appreciate
the elegance of launching watches
that greater accuracy their faithfulness
and world honors confirmed that judgment
from the world's finest watches
long-chain watches alone at one ten
worlds
grand prizes
twenty-eight gold medal awards at
highest honors for accuracy from
government
observatories
yes the problem of selecting a christmas
gift
of great prestige for someone near and
dear is indeed most happily sold with
the launching watch
yet you may buy and probably give alone
gene watch this christmas
for as little as seventy one fifty
and they are at
if you pay
seventy one fifty or more for a watch
you are paying the price of the laundry
and you should insist
on getting the launching the world's
most on earth watch
the world's most other christmas gift
pradnya product of the laundry in
britain or what company
since eighteen sixty six
maker of what it's about five correct
we invite you to join us for the long
gymkhana school
television journal of important issues
of the hour
broadcast on behalf of launching
worlds most powerful opt
and whatnot
distinguished companion
world all of the wrong treatment
this is david rocks speaking for your
regular host right now
reminding you of the quarantine
and britain or what
all sold and service from coast to coast
by more than four thousand leaving too
early
who proudly display this sample
agency for launching widnall watch
all all all
on our hard work offline we all along
plunging watchers have one ten world
program prizes twenty eight gold medals
and more on this for accuracy than any
other time please
launching the world's most honored
watchers made and guaranteed by the
launching with mall watch company
it's time for the long james caan itself
television journal of the important
visions of the art
brought to you every monday wednesday
and friday
a presentation of the launching mcnaught
company
later on
long-chain the world's most on a lot
naw distinguished companions of the
world on a daunting
good evening this is frank nine mail
introduce our color that there is for
this edition of the launching props
mr bernard shaw offer editor and
commentator
mister william bradford killing
editor of the american mercury
our distinguished guests for this
evening is the owner of a bummer
ferguson
united state senator from michigan
in this spontaneous and unrehearsed
discussion
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speaker
partition audience for similar curative
one-man crime buster in detroit
and as a distinguished member of the
senate
specifically circus what are your
committee assignments at the moment
i'm a member of the judiciary committee
also of the policy committee
the appropriations
and uh...
if you get your committee the
subcommittee
course is concerned with security at the
moment is business
subcommittee of that
internal security
navigation
that committee is concerned with date
presidents uh... current efforts
to enforce victor censorship on the
american press i believe
it is concerned with apple
and want to be in your position sir i
have your oppose the president's efforts
to make censorship specter on the press
yes i have opposed that the reason the
bottom
old the rosa
i believe that in the republic such as
well
that we must have freedom of the press
freedom of thought
one of our fundamental
we must have
i was free
the danger is that
use of the weapon
of censorship
haha cardio
apology karen that sound
apology kerrigan at the end of the
national defense how frequent debate
with publication of news and national
defense of course i'm a firm believer
i've stated on the senate floor though i
believe you me
and there are certain things in the
national defense
that day
should determine whether or not
it's for are secure
you can't wear
on your cards
all of the
of the nation
military status
in fear
reconstruction finance committee sir
uh... pitted decided what information
properly the province in the united
states we probably would not have had
some of the recent revelations woodley
you wouldn't have had
and as i say
three-week government
most of the censorship
to attempt
things from the public take the order
after the presentation
let's give good faith
to his issuing upon the question of
security
but he was delegating to each one
off his mate
in the various departments and agencies
the right to determine
on their own
was to be security neil p_s_ prop one a
m
anything that might be embarrassing to
wouldn't you say you have that he might
having more reasonable
approach to life
and that the people would accept it with
greater recent if
if he had issued such an order
uh... together with the press with the
selected group of the press to discuss
it then too
to express that judgment on these
various kinds of orders including
military steps
hoover's widow but
he should have taken the precedent
discussed the whole matter
and first if there were sufficient
causes
had a voluntary censorship
and then
couldn't on rely on a voluntary when
then he should have used the next
anthony
real censorship on security
senator i believe that your
endemic karen subcommittees which he
remembered
has also been considering the matter of
the institute of public relations
and particularly uh... controversial
figure mister jackson
now are
what are your views and
jessup case
multi
i would say that's and i'm not going to
draw a new job
tonight because we have not finished
the hearings are going on around
my work on the bench is almost talked me
below
full judgment on my website
is in the record
i'll say that
that so far the record disposes
that there was a penetration
in the institute office of the privilege
all bones
who at least
we're giving aid and comfort to the
communist bloc
you have heard senators
standard-bearer
former governor staffs and i believe the
four years since he was the even out of
date
mhm appeared before the publicity i'd
like to ask one question that when she
was saying that
sense uh... mister jessica himself said
he was a member of the market for his
committee
and other dari let's say you right wing
organizations that is somewhat
incompatible form to be charged with
both that and communist affiliation but
when she say
that regardless of what he's charged
with these got pretty near a hundred
percent back in a bad judgment
well i don't want to say it's a hundred
percent that that's blowing a little far
already many jet
we all make mistakes
i think there is some evidence in the
right
some of these judgments were very poor
no i don't think there's any doubt about
that
our audience of course no if you as the
coming in the late senator vandenberg
and his uh... memoirs i understand their
about the published
do you think that they elected to share
in the light on this particular
controversy
they'll shed some a lot
on february the fed
they'll shed the light
that there was a meeting in the white
house
and the question as nineteen fourteen
nineteen forty knots
of furnishing
military aid with the stopping of the
to the national scholar
in china
the uh...
committee in the next few days will
receive
copy of the p
of the senators battery that he wrote
with these on paper and you think that
vandenberg revelation will be damaging
to the cause of mister jessup
and most important dispassionate
controversy
well i think it supports the contention
of mister staff
that the state department
distractions
was perfectly willing to have the aid
stopped
as of that
and that senator robert byrd
was only consulted on that china policy
as i understand that
on that particular occasion
contestants out of my second many i
think about twenty to twenty-five
it was that a pretty well balanced
committee
well great uh... a committee that way
that's another committee on in october
on nineteen hundred and forty nine
that's the committee
that mister sasser was talking about
that's the one that he contends that the
record not show
and they have finally produced a record
showing that they sympathy was on the
side of the recognition albrecht kept
was on a wild palms committee will
decide
you know i i think not
the reason we're investigating that
decanter committed
was that they are so many members are
but were members of the institute of
pacific relation
which we are investigating as to whether
or not there was penetration
the communist or the communist one
the sound that point out that your do
you have
we've appointment that missed ingested
to the ambassador oppose to these
recommended for
i would say that the present time
from what i can learn from the committee
here
that i should be compelled to vote
against the confirmation of mister depth
for this particular pope
allen i tried to reserve judgment as
long as possible on these matters
and uh...
i want to hear all the evidence
but that's the way i would spend the
night nor the focus of that power
audience also knows that you have to do
with taxes and
and money sir sent you an important
member the appropriations committee
now this morning we notice that we have
eleven percent tax increase would you
favor that tax increases
mister newly added voted against that
night
i came to the conclusions of my
conscience really
that i could not vote
for it because i felt that we were
placing the burden on the american
people
that could be avoided by that
all the expenses
invalid
and i sincerely believe
but that was true
having any idea at all
quarter-mile tool in comparison with all
the other things that you probably in
favor of which is nice huge national
defense point paul marshall plan and all
the others
israeli
is avaliable moffett
his considerable or is just a matter of
principle of them
i believe that we could have p
sixty feet
billions of dollars i'd hesitate
mentioning
billions of dollars because it's such an
enormous up
that is very difficult to understand i
like to explain the video as being one
on the entire production
of metropolitan detroit of all the
industry's for a year
because they produce
about ten billion dollars worth
so you can see how much goods at the
earliest
with the amount of automobiles and
everything else that's produced in
upgrades
metropolitan area
senator i'm sure that our audience
wouldn't want to do
leaves before you gave us a prediction
is that when you think taxes will go
even higher in america
well i don't see how they can go much
higher than my reason for saying that
just about three weeks ago i met with
members of the house members of the
senate
and we were discussing respect
and they came to the conclusion
we are about at the bottom of the barrel
some of you think we are through the
bottom
and there are no other greater sources
to actually
yet returns without diminishing returns
ideas that you tax people so much
business goes down
and there's a failure to get taxes
rather than to get more
icy tells of some of you would you
believe as a member the appropriations
committee that we have reached the point
of diminishing returns thank you very
much for being with us tonight
the editorial board for this edition of
the launching promise co laws
mister barone auto show off
and mister william bradford hewitt
our distinguished guests wellesley
honorable fuller ferguson
united states senate uh... promise
i watch maker such as on scene because
that christopher columbus made his great
voyages
before the watch wasn't that
his only timepiece plaza san blas
like this where a specimen from the
haven planetary
this was reporters
every half hour
three hours on the ship for us
for the seven hours of
uh... those days
the only navigating instrument was
account
and so now the gators of today's salute
as the fear of them all
columbus day mocks the launching
milestone
fault one of the thirty eight world's
fair awards won by launching
was this gold medal of this and those
columbia exposition some fifty nine
years ago
the four hundredth anniversary of the
discovery of america uh... what on earth
christopher gulab
i consider how consistently launching
watches have maintained their leadership
over the years
winner refers prizes for more than
three-quarters of the century
including ten world's fair grand prizes
twenty eight gold medals at literally
thousands of awards for accuracy from
the great government observatory
today's launching watches
are off-limits
distinguished for exclusive styling end
up with traditional accuracy and long
life
truly throughout
no other name on a watch means so much
as launching
the world's most on it wont
preemie our product of the laundry and
whatnot what's happening
since eighteen sixty six
maker of watches all of the highest debt
races frank night again reminding you
that the mounting problems build is
brought to you
three times weekly every monday
wednesday and friday
so won't you join us
every monday wednesday and friday
evening at the same time
along jane promise go
a television journal of the important
pieces of the hour
broadcast on behalf of launching
the world's most honored lots
what law distinguished companions of the
world are launching
sold and service
from coast to coast
by more than four thousand beating
joiners
will proudly displayed the emblem
agency for long train but
the or
although on our door rockwall off dog
plunging watchers have one can work
program prizes twenty eight gold medals
and more honors for accuracy than any
other parties
logging the world's most honored
watchers made and guaranteed by the
luncheon with ma watch company
meeting time for the launching comatose
television journal of the implementation
of the out
structure you every monday wednesday and
friday
a presentation of the laundry with na
what happened
later on
launching the world's most ahmed watch
and what
distinguished companion to the world on
and on gene
remain with us right now
now introduce our code of those for this
edition of the loan gene cosco
misdirected baker managing director of
time-life international
and mister henry have
editor of the freemen and contributing
editor of newsweek magazine
our distinguished guests for this
evening is the honorable give or take a
break
united states senate uh... prominent out
the opinions discussed dot necessarily
rows of the speakers
well senator humphrey i see that the new
york times this morning credit you with
a very important victory in helping to
get
that's the presidents reorganization
plan of the internal revenue bureau
the times wrote the victory was left
personal one for the president
but it was for three freshman senators
who led the fight
hubert humphrey of minnesota mike and
ronnie of oklahoma and there will be at
michigan
so put you begin by telling us what the
reorganization plan does that answer
from the key to the reorganization plan
or the crux of the is that if we move
easily
political patronage system from the
uh... office of the collector of
internal revenue
in other words replaces the appointment
of all the collectors of internal
revenue and the many revenue districts
strictly under the civil service system
the competitive america examination
i think this is highly desirable
if we have had uh... plenty of
a demonstration of the inadequacy
uh... be politically appointed
collectors of internal revenue invoices
and opinion upon competence and
technical backward
for the best out of my memory is correct
of the sixty-four present collectors and
seven needed and forced to resign
or discharge
now doesn't that mean that the uh...
president's plan is in effect a plan to
present himself
from uh... making their appointments
rose matter-of-fact
that president truman made no likeness
military or our credibility that he let
that go to another for any president
because may i say that back in the good
old days uh... the days when andrew
mellon was secretary of the treasury we
had an even worse situation than we had
no i don't mean to inject
partisanship into it but it's not really
true that we do not holdovers from the
knowing that they're not always but the
political patronage system just has not
produced the kind of caliber and talent
that we should have been in office is as
important as the crack of internal
revenue is office
plus the fact that they
collectors office is a busy office
you have over seventeen million tax
returns for example about fifty million
taxpayers and when you consider the
tremendous number of taxes that
attractive internal revenue must be
responsible for i think he ought to be
recruited
and hired on the basis of technical
skill background experience and all that
comes with a competitive merit system
examination while senator very very
the passage of the bill was very time
with the idea of march paper tax payment
or close upon us
hi understand that you are in favor of
uneven tighter
is that correct i'm in favor of what i
call late
tighter or eight more on herbal tax
structure that is absolutely true by for
personally believe that the entire tax
structure of our country needs a basic
overhauling it has grown pretty much
like topsy
every time we've needed a little more
revenue we fished around to find some
new way t o batting impacted the pack
structure in the meantime some people
been
fishing around to see how they can get
out of paying taxes senator what
specific recommendations would you like
well my recommendations are have been
turned on
not by myself alone but by many others
over the the years
uh... loophole uh... plugging provisions
uh... by that i mean uh... taking up the
tax structure in reference to it uh...
certain specific uh... tax allowances
org
says special treatment taxes
that we have in the tax system such as
the capital gains tax structure family
partnership sir
leave failure to have withholding upon
corporate bond interest and dividends
that media student one provision of
mediaone depletion allowances for gas
and oil wells or other such cervical tax
matters as corporate spinoff saturday's
both attacked the first one you
mentioned is there anything that
actually had to do about that electorate
recommendation on that
well first of all i wanna make my
position quite clear i think that the
capital gains tax schedule
which is to be differentiated from the
earned income schedule and the corporate
income schedule
is illegitimate packed schedule i mean
it has a legitimate purpose
media purpose
for it when it was enacted was to
promote investment
capital improvement and investment
uh... the original capital gains was for
twenty five percent tax maximum of
twenty five percent
but you had to hold your property or
your bondar your stop for a period of
two years
to give a sense of legitimacy to the
investment
now that period of holding period has
been reduced from two years to one year
to six months
and in the last two sessions of the
congress to try to cut it down to three
months when speculation has been rampant
particularly
at the by the way every time you have a
defense or a war situation they always
want to cut down the holding period
on capital gains of senator isn't it
true that on the other side you cannot
deduct capital losses against income you
can be done except except against about
three thousand dollars
so capital losses are not deductible
uh... therefore you can't jump at
capital gains has fallen contribute
mister has and i'm sure that you and
i'll have got a disagreement about that
because when you talk about capital
gains and capital losses
you can deduct capital losses from your
capital gain capital gains an audio
incoming house yet
quickly but i think i'm sad your capital
gains tax to your income tax but you
cannot deduct a capital losses from your
income that you have a rectified
when i when i think that it had right
window killings know what you wrote an
article in the government loses entails
you won't tolerate that government wins
that the failed
we do the taxpayer and the people who
get begumpet against her income at the
simple fact senate mister has worked
there are no everywhere so it was a poll
in your life economist and you know that
there are three basic tax structures in
this country the kind i pay which is
earned income tax
the kind of corporation pays which is
corporate tax
and the kind of a speculator phase which
is capital gains tax
and the night of speculating on the
market pays a lower tax rate than a
worker that's earning seventy five
hundred dollars on their short-term gain
unless you already know and i think
maybe pay the same as my music is once
again the people that is not considered
a short term they speculated aggravate
your smuggler exit around sixty eight
years to require
computers for capital gains when i'm
sorry mister has learned is that if you
lose in the capital gains market
you can meet you can deduct your losses
from your capital gains
and you only pay twenty
that price per cent of the present law
up on your ernie but you know i i i
don't know why defined rules as a wager
if i lose as a wage earner one-year i
cannot go back in deducted from my taxes
i paid the other here
but you don't have it as it may senator
humphrey that
that's an area in which in which i
believe uh...
both or all three sides of the of the of
the argument are graded whatever change
might be made would be comparatively
moderate there's another area
uh... you mentioned earlier that earlier
the phrase depletion allowance when we
hear a great deal about what you you
care to explain and and in general terms
what the principle of the depletion
allowance is yes i did a little
historical background on the depletion
allowance it was enacted in the congress
i believe in the year nineteen twenty
five or twenty six and right around that
period
and the purpose of the depletion
allowance for gas and oil and some
mining interests like so preferred to
have an extended for a bit of an
extended to
about forty five commodities and by the
way that's that's another one of the
tricks we even got another place their
shelves nalla depletion allowance has
been expanded by moms are everybody
congress by the congress over the
objections of the executive every time a
special interest groups and unravel boys
want to get enough last time will make a
decision wicked they have a good way to
allow when israel replace admiral i
think a depletion allowance that's fair
and equitable in terms of the scientific
type of the technology of the day's
legitimate now the purpose of the
depletion allowance of first was to
promote exploration of oil and gas
uh... fields
so we have a depletion allowance of
twenty seven and a half percent
but since that time and i say
the scientific knowledge of broker i
guess field is and where loyalty of his
is much better than it was in nineteen
twenty five
but it's not that it had also told
senators affect an advocate that they
actually know how much uh... oil is
under the ground not not in every adult
and they don't know how much they
dictating activity has perhaps looked
and then a business gets what he calls
me because she shouldn't allow sick you
at one hundred thousand dollar thailand
and indonesia if it's not a depletion
allowance is a twenty seven and a half
percent up on your bro's revenue
well everybody to get in three years and
that would be right you are likely to be
made even longer plus the fact plus the
fact that amendment drills oil wells and
finds a devil
when he finally hits one he can take all
of the deductions for all of the losses
that he had before
serotonin five separate gratuities or
benefits given by the government for
mining
and gas and oil
glorified but you don't have a nineteen
twenty five and i say that it's
absolutely wrong in the year nineteen
fifty two do have a depletion allowance
of twenty seven and a half percent on
both income when you have twenty-five
special benefits debate but you didn't
have the time of the law was enacted
plus a tremendous change in a great many
respects between nineteen twenty five in
nineteen fifty two however insofar as as
the supply of oil and other critical raw
materials are concerned that's correct
the suppliers even the norm supply today
is much greater than it was in nineteen
oh nine when he saw it in and they have
a better bond markets are vast oil wells
are guilty of securities
and a profit percentage of gas and oil
development is about any other commodity
in the american market
well senator at the last question is a
final question do you think that there
is a prospect in the near future other
reduction of taxes generally or do you
think the prospect is for higher taxes
well i think it greatly depends upon the
international situation
and i think the american people must
know
at the high schedule attacks today is
primarily the result of the great
international crisis it is my feeling
that as we level off and people often
are rearmament program that we can get
these taxes down and i think they should
come down
earned income tax in the corporate pacs
are terribly hot
they're very high
and it's for that reason i say that we
should point out the special treatment
areas
and thereby be able to
at least level off the earned income tax
rate and the corporate tax rate so that
you don't knock out and send even
business and that you do not place an
undue burden
up on date of the individual it is
having a pretty tough time making it go
when they simply did period
well senator thank you very much for
your answer they've been very
illuminating the appreciate very much
for being with us tonight
the editorial board for this edition of
the loan gene carla scope laws
mr edgar baker and mister henry have
our distinguished guests
wellesley honorable hubert h_ hombre
united states and other prominent supper
mean winter olympic games recently
completed at oslo norway where
exclusively time by launching
to attend and a hundred for the second
this telegram that i have here
is our award
non jeannette britain used for a long
time keeping during the winter olympic
games nineteen fifty two
all worked perfectly
thanks for your valuable cooperation
and it's time
the organizing committee
now that's the one of the program
and wherever so please
lunging was actually a facial watch for
the three great olympic sports events
during the past year
the winter olympics adults smoked
the ferry boat of aryan games like a
ruckus in venezuela
and the first pan-american games have
been one of the i_r_a_'s
in argentina
and now we are proud to announce that
the united states olympic committee has
selected launching watches
broad mining all events
for the selection of the united states
olympic team of nineteen fifty two
so you see whatever precise timing is
important
in sports a_b_a_ shannon science as in
everyday life
the preeminent choice of watches is long
jane
the old may watch in history win
tamraz's background prizes
twenty eight gold medals at the highest
honors for accuracy from the leading
government observatory
long jane the world's most on iraq
creamy our product of the laundry mat na
watch company
since eighteen sixty six
maker of watches of the highest
join us every monday wednesday and
friday evening at the same time
for the long gene promised
the television journal of the important
there certainly are
broadcast on the drop-off laundry
the world's most on a block
and whatnot distinguished companion
for the world are launching
riverbank nine reminding you again
that long gene and whatnot what those
are thrown out of it
by more than four thousand leading to us
from coast to coast
probably display their family
patron saint paul long game but not a
lot
time for the launching promised us
television journal of the implementation
of the hour brought to you every monday
by the state and trust
presentation of a laundry list of all
what happened
later on
launching the world's most on it a lot
and what
distinguished companion to the world on
and on gene
good evening this is frank night
may i introduce our collateral for this
edition of the launching promise co
mister william bradford puree editor of
the american mercury and mister robert
vito brannan editor of business week
magazine
our distinguished guests for this
evening is the art of our being and i
united states and other from new york
senator i have to pleasure to have your
again on the grounds group tonight sir
and earlier this week
we have had uh...
mr franklin roosevelt junior and mister
abraham on who have summed up the issues
for our viewers
and tonight sir because we're not on
will not be on the air monday night
because of the
large wound up programs
tonight is our last program before the
election
and would like for you to sum up for the
republicans justice mister roosevelt and
mister harmon has done for the democrats
now sir uh... great deal of emphasis has
been put on the korean issue in these
last few days of the campaign
an hour democratic spokesman
have accused general eisenhower of being
a little unfair and injecting the issue
that he would go to korea
now number one certain do you think that
if he has been an unfair tactical on the
part of general eisenhower
material uh... certainly do not
then at the same time i'll tell you how
much i appreciate being on this program
i think the general eisenhower
in undertaking a strip of that kind of
doing exactly what he should do he is a
military man
one of the greatest generally that more
time this country
do you think its primary military
problems i don't know i have political
also
but i think both military and political
and i think the general probably could
get more out of the cold war there
than almost anybody else in this country
would not be acquainted with the first
ten g_o_p_ primary information gathering
for that i would assume that's what he
intends to find out what
is being done although there are all the
equipment is all the supplies are highly
mentality morale is it firsthand because
of course he said this tremendous
experience is two people is that
leading understand he is your sense that
uh...
that that general eisenhower would have
a better chance of settling the korean
conflict then governor stevenson
i certainly do
and uh...
one of the things that general at her
rejected was
the fact that he would step up the
training of self korea's with the hope
that he could relieve our own troops of
bearing that brought evade the
front-line battle
and for that uh... he was accused of
some dishonesty
now sir do you think that
general eisenhower has a valid point
they are a lot of a gentleman please
letter that was written
indicating that he had done that she
demo completed done all of you can do or
could do within this capacity within
this uh... they live
the than the
the lives of the supplies and equipment
all concerned there
would permit
indicated that more can be done on the
fact that gentleman fleet no said
there are stated as i understand that
more can be done at the end more quickly
be able to do more more supplies you'd
be able to do more
initials that uh... general eisenhower
was absolutely justified issued a
statement what would you think would be
a reason
necessary supplies and such would be
withheld
i would only be against
training workers
i don't answer that question i don't
know if there's a real estate any
official statement made on the subject
of the store sisters confidences offers
such a statement
that can see what it would be a catalyst
and why we shouldn't the what
utterly tired sick and tired of this
whole korean tragedy
and i think this sunday we kept the
south koreans and the condition where
they can hold the front lines as fires
are able to hold on the better offer all
of us the u_n_ and ourselves concluded
and quietly south koreans haven't been
placed in a condition where they can
occupy the front lines i don't know i
haven't seen any excuse of any kind
offer to that
well sir uh...
do you think that generalizing
powers uh... suggestion that we use more
agents to fight agents is a
is a sounds that is the fundamental out
there on which uh... we were supposed to
operate in the orient from the beginning
we've always understood in this country
that uh... if we're going to fight
any part of asia
mainland asia we should not do it with
the troops of the western powers
the very fact that our western troops
are doing the fighting
automatically gives the give to our
action the wrong impression
where the lows against two were fighting
or at least those who may be able to
remote area are concerned that the
fathers of western invasion differently
or asian powers can deal with his
attorneys
well i think what
near if there is any asian power they
can deal with attorneys
well yes i think if you know i think
you're suffering is properly trained to
deal with them insofar as possible
insofar as the numbers of from that
their twenty million people of south
korea
i don't know why they can't provide not
talked to hold on for awhile moved as a
matter of fact we've got to bring the
south korean thing to a termination one
of these days
and i i i must say that these people
that say that this is only a peninsula
it's not a part of the mainland of aidid
says that we're not in the mainland war
has just we are out peter forrest is a
potential a_t_f_ well route a hit far
greater
snot island
then we've always have been led to
believe and i know of no reason why it
isn't true
that if we ever get on the mainland war
in asia we're going to be a bit white
and that can very easily happen in korea
or casualties now running as you know
over the power of the week
slots are now moving on the west jenna
regarded as the second big issue
and sort of summing up what's been said
about communists
any government
star do you think
that general eisenhower's been on sound
ground their or that they've been
anything on fair in his uh... approach
to that issue
nothing out there that i know of
whatever the whole record as indicated
that there is a general position is
absolutely sound absolute indicated
terms of your particular interest
senator
terribly happy pc question is whether
the
is a major issue mister well i think i
think
you determine that the pcl use a broader
term i think it's a question of civil
rights i think that's really
fundamentally vital questions today
i believe there a way that we've got to
begin practice what we preach in this
country
at every meeting what we say in what we
profess to believe it's night time we
began to carry are configured character
since the mix of new york state
legislation on that subject fireworks
where they are under welfare of the took
all that's been a while the
do you feel that your own views
and i'm eddie mair in accord with the
views of the platform
for the republican national platform
there about the national platform which
was created that you're talking about
not quite as they have access to
that plank is created in such broad
terms that we can put it
for a
fifty pcs you desire to call it that
with enforcement provisions
at any time that we can
possibly get a chance to go ahead with
it there's nothing in our platform it
prohibits anything of a kind in fact is
left wide open
actually were intercepted said don't
mind because it is as important actually
and during the course of that convention
during the course of the committee
action on the matter in the convention
the a proposition
to limit epi pc activities to the level
of the states and not to permit it on
the federal level
what they see it
in committee
level thirty nine thirty
demonstrating definitely that the
position taken by the profile but the
platform committee resolutions committee
was definitely opposed to eliminate
that the p_c_ operations to the state
level
and thereby leaving the door wide open
for the federal court
that there was uh... those of our
viewers
concerned with civil liberties civil
rights
and who want during the next four years
fish the uh... more and more dot in that
direction
do you think that they can safely go
with the republicans in nineteen fifty
two
the lap of a c l_ e_ inevitable will get
anything done to the democrats
i mean the very adept back of that is
utterly ridiculous because the history
of civil rights
these during the last twenty years
sure that the republicans
from the standpoint of the filibuster
the attempt to get culture
from the standpoint of activity and the
national legislation itself
them from the standpoint of the record
all the way through the republicans have
done for more information all rights
legislator standpoint
none of the democrats and i think they
really want below the details of that
because it's rather warm exhausted but
they're actually is
the republicans have done just about
twenty times as much in the senate
if the republicans control congress next
year
would you expect to hear
some civil rights legislation would pass
no effect less civil rights legislation
but we can talk to the filibuster that
their first hurdle we have to make a
massive that's for the drive to be made
directly on
getting a culture provisions will apply
it to his call changed
is such a way
that weekend
photo another stop for the filibuster by
majority vote of the members of the
summer
when that's done that we can go ahead
the civil rights legislation and that's
going to be a big hurdle to get over it
we've got to get over we got use every
ounce of energy we have to meditate
moving to the other big issue sir
a labor legislation
many of our viewers of course are
interested in labor legislation uh...
believe that uh...
mister stevenson has promised to repeal
the taft hartley act
outright
now what can you say on that such a stir
in something we're talking about what
the status of the position i guess and
start with that because i recall mister
stephens of position prior to a
nomination was not in favor of the
leaders of both repeal the fat hartley
act in favor
two men
many got the nomination or immediately
thereafter almost changes position came
up a repeal the act
well now let me just point out what
repeal of moscow's compared to men
you know i think that one gains by
repeal is a change in the name of the
act
what is needed
are very broad members that uh...
hartley act
to bring him in the line
with current conditions and also take
out of it removed from it
particular sections
which are not fair
and which are not workable in large
measure
that should have been done back in
nineteen forty eight
or if we're trying to get some labor
relations legislation through the taft
hartley act in the first instance
expected in nineteen forty eight new
finish the job i correcting the defects
in the act
unfortunately the president nine states
thought he had a wonderful political
argument there are one of a political
issue
and he did all he could to block it and
do is control over the members of the
congress leaders anyway in his party in
the congress he was able to prevent
any effective legislation being passed
by congress during the period of time
from nineteen forty eight the present
that's what happened
i see as a final brief questions are
sent you yourself are
a running for reelection in new york
how do you think you your approval in
your race and i'm for general eisenhower
onto well i'm not going to predict
regarding myself but what the wind
service of the worst thing i can if i'm
elected to carry on the work i've been
going down the congressman
works the best of liability and i so
appreciate winning effect get their
forest fire states concern the state's
one republican
for eisenhower well thank you very much
for being with us
the opinions that well speakers
expressed tonight on cod liver oil
the editorial board for this edition of
the launching promised both laws mister
william bradford healy and mister robert
b copa
our distinguished guests will be on a
boat are being analyzed
united states senate are from new york
next use the millions of americans will
go to the polls to exercise their right
and privilege as citizen
don't let your boat they lost my friend
for freedom of choice is a very precious
freedom
that extends throughout our life in this
way for profit even to the things we've
i
and his two help you make your choice to
give you freedom of choice in the watch
that you buy that we can do on this
program the facts about laundry
it should mean something and it does
mean something that in competition with
the world's best watches long gene is
the only wants to win ten worlds that
grand prizes and twenty eight gold medal
award
it should mean something and it does
mean something that in competition with
the world's most accurate watch
long gene has one compass prizes and
competitive accuracy trials
at the great government observatory
so if you wish to chose for your own
auto select as a gift
just about the finest watch made
anywhere in the world
the facts about launching should
convention
from personal experience
millions of discriminating men and women
the world over
have made this statement through
no other name on a watch means so much
as launching
the world's most alcohol
premium product of the logging but not
all that stuff
since eighteen sixty six
maker of what is up but
we invited to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time
well on teen pasta
a television journal of the important
dates as if they are
broadcast on the top all launching the
world's mohammed watch
distinguish companion
world all night long chain
the oral longer or drop off in a long
one
plunging watchers have one can wear a
program prizes twenty eight gold medals
and bar honors for accuracy than any
other countries
launching the world's most honored
watches made and guaranteed by the
launching what small watch company
time for the launching monitor
television journal of the implementation
of the aisle structural you every monday
wednesday and friday
presentation of the laundry list of all
what happened
later on
launching the world's most ahmed watch
and what
distinguished companion to the world on
and on gene
good evening business frank night
now introduce our colored letters for
this edition of the mounting problems co
mister william bradford hewitt editor of
the american lecture
and mr donald dot raja as an editor of
the new york herald tribune
our distinguished guest for this evening
is the honorable john jay stockman
united states and other problem out
about
the opinions expressed
are necessarily those of the kids
senator sparkling along in many
activities in the senate you're chairman
of the committee and small business
which is of
mounting problem
tonight we'd like to have you tell us
some of the things you or your career
doing to help the small businessman
for server would you be kind enough to
tell us what you consider to be the
major problem from small businessmen of
america
i believe that right now the major
problem confronting the
small businesses none of them are good
news
getting a sufficient uh... materials
with which to continue operating his
business is there anything you wear
committee can go to jail materials to
live
we can't travel in the period but we can
certainly keep back to the various
agencies that they do that
you know what to make certain that small
business gets its
uh... fachet absent in internal when you
talk about small businesses remain a
small manufacturing denied
ordinarily that would be true although
not necessarily true because uh...
service organizations that would be
small business just same however
they're not confronted with this problem
of materials materials that's really
uh...
there's a problem confronting
manufacture and and how do you define a
small business what do you think that
was a small businesses
the uh... defense department uh...
sat-sun arbitrary definition of small
business as any
business
uh... which wickets associates
employees not more than five hundred
persons
now can you make a big general statement
about
miss in this business now the small
businesses father a generally are
suffering uh... at present
yes a great many small businesses are
suffering because
since it outbreak of uh... war in korea
there has been a scarcity of steel
aluminum copper
all of those have been the principle of
anything anyone section of the country
hurt worse than other sections
i don't know that we could save one
section was hurt worse than another
but uh...
it's too spotty
some cities are in very quietly but yes
i wanted i reside here are some some so
you can find a surplus labour areas that
are yes uh... all of those however are
not due to a small business problems for
instance i see all of you cut back in
detroit
yes but don't know about providence
rhode island for instance yes uh... that
is one area that i had in mind another
goal there is primarily the uh...
along with the colors
over swallowing colors and things of
that time yes that's true now what would
you do it all the jeweler in providence
we believe that the defense department
ought to find uh... some use for their
men making up precision instruments so
turning instruments fuses and things of
that car could you give me an example of
where your committee
as help they certain
small business
yes i i i i'll go back to lou can i give
you many
but uh... since you've got to something
and i'll tell you one day
you know or in every he already love
every shooting
there are certain number of blue
attacked
i don't know what you know that and not
but it's true
on the head of every one of those taxes
and little tiny washer
all you get put your appealable issues
unless you've got those washes
all of those watchers are made by just
uh... two or three thousand homosexuals
appear new england
four years old but i got to the point
where they couldn't get any go to steal
which make a little watchers
and because they couldn't make the
watchers the shoe industry was
confronted with a very serious situation
we got busy and got uh... steel for
their own to make that watchers here
took racketeer dozens of examples that
you took that still from some military
operation they do not know recently sold
it to steal was gentlemen that not all
that was plain stealing just simply
uh...
so mistaken been made and they didn't
get their fair share senator on our show
the other night
uh... missed out the framing of the
manpower commissions here
and he told us that
food in the plans were being made now on
the assumption
that this uh... defense emergency will
continue over a period of ten to fifteen
years
now in uh... and you're thinking of your
committee in the senate
are you making the same assumption that
we have something like a ten to fifteen
year plan before us
i don't think we can safely make any
other assumption
uh... let me say this bill which uh...
at the present time we're building up
that doesn't mean that we're going to
continue to build up for over a period
of ten to fifteen years
i believe the present program calls for
getting to load up into our maximum
production by on july first nineteen
fifty
then we'll be able to level all
and i think that is what he must have
had in mind that you were pure to
connect with fifteen years level off at
peak production unit
capacity yes not necessarily that will
be producing the tapes and don't forget
me to look to the point that we can
produce them
tell me that senator do you find that
they government
the per se they administration is uh...
sympathetic
through small business or is it dealing
mostly with the larger businesses
well i don't think that to mister
certainly yellow color
does go together
uh... yes i think uh... i mean i love
the question i mean and opened and the
president of the government that
cognizant of the problem that uh...
small business day
yes sometimes i think that some of the
agencies are not as
came the alert to them as they ought to
be
arcadia what uh... michael has been
it's a good this that it's so kisi
and say
to do business with big business
yeah all first of all they have their
representatives there they help work out
everything they have find records they
know that they're capable of doing it
that the other than the president's also
for that
it's easier to do business with them
what we believe they ought to exert a
little extra effort
in order to
keep this uh...
hiding the central part of our national
economy bodily remember this
that uh... ninety percent of the
businesses work for small businesses
senator that that very intersting
with our audience also knows you is a
very influential seven senator
and i'm sure they'd like to have your
dues
where do you stand in the political
firmament
uh... you are a uh... a southern new
dealer
you think of yourself as being a new
deal senator who i don't think of myself
as being the new deal senator or
i've always felt that uh... i would
rather independent and i think most of
the southerners all
now where do you stand in the fight now
the presidential photo u
the for senator russell for the
presidential nomination
the alabama delegation supported senator
russell in the nineteen forty eight
uh... convention in philadelphia
uh... that we think very highly of
senator russell
i don't know what and that i would
rather support and heat
and uh... and beauty
the traditional seven position on uh...
on uh... civil rights legislation also
called civil rights legislation i do
suppose general eisenhower becomes a
republican
nominee
uh... if you have any predictions on the
outcome of the vote in the south
i would say this is hard for me too
invasion
fissile voting for anybody under two
republican emblem yeah you know there's
a tradition down now here's larry now by
what we have the you know crowing
roosters are simple and people when they
go to the polls in november
don't mail build them but when they do
go or they like them make their crawls
under that rooster
will be pretty hard to get them to make
the crawls under an elephant regardless
of who was a lot of electric but let me
say this derived the power is very very
popular in the south
more popular than any other republican
candidate you i think that's true
i think that's true
uh... here also a powerful member of the
banking and currency committee senator
and our audiences are a great deal about
the reconstruction finance corporation
now uh...
do you think that uh...
all of the correction has been cleared
up there
obligated hairs
all i think senator fulbright in his
uh... subcommittee did an excellent job
in logging in to the r_n_c_ ad nauseam
set time there's been a reorganization
object along the line of senator
fulbright himself suggested we have a
single administrator who just uh...
uh... descendant of just confirming new
and i believe you're going to do a good
job than on the side because taxes which
a great many people are thinking of
about this time
where do you stand
uh... you drive believe economy man did
this year do you want to cut the budget
yes i do
would you cut foreign aid
well i think tornado let me put it this
way i pulled the foreign relations
committee had bill will come before us
i don't know that we will examine it
most
and the last year we cut it down a
little more than a billion dollars
are you know it should not be surprised
to see it got some days here also
whether your prediction for the cut on
the overall budget
i don't know i'm also on the joint
economic committee and analyze
through three weeks we've been wrestling
with that very uh... problem
oskaloosa it's alright for me to say
that our report will probably come out
tomorrow morning and we're going to
recommend that every effort be made to
bring the budget into balance
and to do that that would be a lot uh...
well was that hard to tell but it
probably would be in tokyo and cutting
the budget up something like seven or
eight billion dollars maybe even as much
as ten billion how much would you cut
from foreign aid under this and and let
me put it this way i wanted me to pay so
that i don't prejudge it if i had to
make a rough guess i would guess that
uh... the billion dollars at least would
be cut out of the foreign aid
then are you uh... in
how you wouldn't believe unbalanced
budget yourself yet very strongly i
think that uh... non-violence declining
without the inflationary pressures that
are generated as a result of it
could give us the tremendous a lot of
trouble and what do you think about
taxes that are you in favor of cutting
taxes as soon as possible
all yes but uh...
i don't know that scope would love to be
a good time for a couple of years and
have now
so i thought you were asked me if i vote
in favor of raising taxes that's what
uh... both the talk is about no i'm not
in favor of uh... increasing taxes
you're not in favor of increasing them
you think that they'll remain about
where they are for at least another two
years yeah especially noticeable in the
world
under two-year answer that alin suit
very much appreciate your views tonight
thank you for being with us
the editorial board for this edition of
the launching promise toh laws
mister william bradford killing and mr
donald i rogers
our distinguished guests was the
honorable john jay spot them united
states and other from alabama
you heard it said of course
most people know the price of everything
and the value of nothing now that's just
not true
certainly not for long gene watches for
more people know the value alone on gene
watch
then its products
you know princeton's
that there are many models of the
world's most allen watch which sell for
as little
and seventy one fifty
if you pay seventy one fifty or more per
watch
not paying the price of a launching the
world's most on iraq
why not insist on getting on on g
honored for excellence and elegance
five-ten world's background prizes and
twenty eight gold medals
honored for actors they buy a new merlot
honors from the great
government observatories
ahmed for honesty
in fields of precise timing in sports
eighty asian exploration and science
so if you wish to purchase of varity by
and watch
i feel so
or as a gift
for the value in the walkthrough vide
and that's your choice the laundry
the world's most all night long
creamy our product of the lawn gene with
not what's happening
since eighteen sixty six
maker of watches
called the highest debt
this is brian night again inviting you
to be with us
every monday wednesday and friday
evening at the same time or other long
team promised
a television journal of the important
pieces of the hour
broadcast on the drop-off laundry
the world's most ali mahdi
what more distinguished companion for
the world all night long jane
sold and service from coast to coast
by more than four thousand leading to
others
who proudly display this a m
agency for long gene but not all options
giant lava long game
television journal of the implementation
of the allah
structural you every monday wednesday
and friday
presentation of the laundry list of all
what happened
later on
lodging the world's most al-kidwa
and whatnot
distinguished companion to the world on
its own g
good evening this is frank night
mary interviews are co-editors for this
edition of the loan gene collinsville
mister william bradford healing
editor of the american mercury and mr
dot on dot rogers
an editor of the new york herald tribune
our distinguished guests for this
evening
if they are one of those of oligopoly
united states senate are from wisconsin
the opinions expressed
star necessarily those of the speaker
senator mccarthy are probably the most
controversial figure on the american
political scene
mccarthy and mccarthyism oh well
i'm sure our audience is very much
interested in your political career so
suppose we start right out so it's all
us about the campaign in wisconsin
you're running for reelection i believe
projections and estimates about mister
rogers except i heard the new moon
announced today
it will be
tough close contest i think in the prime
in the primary gathering public an
opponent
and empty
three or four republican opponents might
hurt now
and hope to encrypt missed
we heard the new mam island schmidt
announced today
this is an hour for governors of that
he ran for governor two years ago and
uh...
through the signs moguls
if mister human-edited
ineffective campaign heats
here's an effective campaign and he
regard mr smith
is running as your uh... perhaps most
uh... dangerous opponent
i wouldn't want to solve dealing and
running man
saying they were not dangerous tracy and
and uh...
you say that
uh... the pan am flight would be serious
what kind of panera do you have been an
open primary to both democrats
republicans vote in the republican plan
m unusual situations comes in june
leading multinational the republican
primary search engine
and the republicans of course could go
to the democratic primary in security
that means that if
lean democrats could induce enough of
their
democrats more republican primary vote
against me
you could make a very rough cut one
hundred for mccarthyism couldn't it
representative said that uh...
and i think
this uh...
don't get the muslim democrat vote
something similar to me
we had some awfully good democrats this
conflict has got a bit
those their campaigns that uh...
considerable amounts of money will be
spent from outside the state the
expected money will be spent there said
in the wisconsin the travail the feature
there's a fortunate son was killed so
many conflict i think there's more
champion literature put out by my
opposition up to this time the normally
has been done in her campaign
went up about uh...
condition that i should say
there's a book coming out
the written by
computers and movement in repose
originally the recall of the hairy it
for the missing link
i guess i mean they have floridians and
systems rheumatism or something like
that
can we all the usual
smear and innuendo soon it's going to be
a
unpleasant campaign well speaking of
support from our other state you have
banned supported or endorsed by such
general manager location etc
an upturn close doomed except their
support you'd be welcome i don't think
it
endorsed or supported by jealousness or
people stop not till i know let let me
say this
i'm not going to
cancer from demand
parties reputation
panel certainly in the reputation of the
anti a snack
i'm sure the new
one can point to anything in my
background the show that i am
anti any particular group
i have a narrow mind votes nothing else
i have here senator mccarthy a
publication called
headlines in one's behind them
mother publication called
conspiracy in the fall of jerome case or
in the military is
not with the publications religion
mention your name in here
that endorsing your room
and they also mention that uh... general
eisenhower is uh... part of a semantic
to overthrow the world
part of the literature that's
circulating about you know you know
about these publications no no i don't
minnesota
aznar or changes nominated
you know and i think we'll have a good
nominee
them by saying i have a heart transplant
don't want to exclude
the possibility of another great
american league general macarthur homer
it's on the contents
blumenthall disturbed about
the americanism the loyalty
uh... any of the
front-running candidates within twelve
million americans i think they're good
republicans did
from the animations and administered at
any
any publication which
intimates that there's anything on
american
but many of our front-running candidates
whose mistake
putting it mildly they all of our
candidate in your opinion or or solid
american job malval's front-running
candidates all those that have been
mentioned in connection with
feedforward agent orange and white issue
one of our own general eisenhower you do
not believe should be circulated
and what's in the publication is
religious
all i can say is that uh...
and into not worth the presidential race
i've been fully satisfied
that regardless of which one of the
men
nominated
he'll be a good candidate
and we've got a bunch of the delegates
at chicago good americans
don't be afraid to support him to the
hilton tentative that regardless of who
the nominees on the republican ticket
well the senator now speaking of
campaigns
do you expect the campaign outside of
wisconsin uh... between now and november
also move
heavy obligations to other senators
manhood
complaint and things looked black
customers
but his communist government
some of them on the so-called marginal
states
use this link to having difficulty
innocent of racist i think that i can
help them
i'm looking to their states let me say
this that uh...
fifty
republicans should take over the summit
i happen to making id number on me
investigating committee that means of
appears to be concerned one of the
senate investigating committee in the
defeatism
committee one promise
that leavenworth won't hold on
you're going to use the same tactics
that your viewers gradovs
incidents name tactics
the cd if you have a committee that
investigated
you don't use the same tactics to use
when you have no
no committee no part of subpoenaed
we've got to
jagan root out
the communists
and the crooks knows her bedroom
bravery on the committee
uh... so if you look for a subpoena you
can get the records
and if we have a republican president
uh... would be able to get those records
i'm sure
uh... it will be needed
a less spectacular flight
much more effective
seats it's difficult when you're all
along
it was uh...
the entire power of this federal
bureaucracy against you
difficult to believe that you see
we have the exposed
got the government
eleven
uh... of those over to me
some of the son of a convicted others
before the grand jury but all of the
government onto the loyalty program
driven all you do it all that ah... mr
lamb or has been
requested not to leave david the country
switzerland was not willy loman
because he was no longer
in the government has been used as an
advisor
but i didn't kill him once he left
so that they are very happy new year
long
here right you spoke of uh... minister
something in
the preliminary research mister rogers
the state department has been taking
credit for the
uh... band of online mowers leaving the
country
that but i think that is uh...
used improper because the state
department issued on behalf of it
because the justice department
the justice department either folderol
mister please division
need is a division
answered close the canadian border is
closed nixon borders closed atlantic
close the pacific do a lot more
don't let him leave the country as a
result of our no attorney general
unlined
the previous attorney general with uh...
we're gramps was a
good friend of mine
name
very happy to see the new attorney
general currently going about his
germany good serious fashion kind of
name and they could just pelican
sighting
if i'm making predictions of with his
predictions might
means if the state department
musictory
but apart their disposal to try and get
a lot more out of this country
within the next two or three months you
might have reasons for saying that uh...
very good reasons and then i suggest
that cute
what's what happens over the next few
weeks in few months long standoff let me
understand these contradictions that
you've made senator they sound very
important to me
here are predicting for our viewers that
within the next few weeks
the state department
will use its influence to get professor
ladder mort outside the country
kenya and weinstein
trying to keep
now and then i could but i
for reasons which i'll explain if you
don't see red just couldn't do it if you
didn't have the other end of the
understand why within a matter of
alright i'll answer my alaska collect
our viewers' attention to your
prediction million lives
and then that the other thing that i'd
like to get very clear because it sounds
important
if you're elected re-elected senator and
if there's a republican victory this
fall
uh... then you will be chairman of the
president uh... question on is the
mccarran committee would like to meet
with you judy
the seeing
is now known as the some virtually
committee
the truman committed see special summit
mismanagement icy and you're also made a
prediction that uh... if you
and get control of that committee
that day you expect to uh... and fill up
the leavenworth then a few more of the
federal prisons
is that correct isn't business in future
good any
good american in charge of the
investigating committee
cited as one other two that you
mentioned the book and there's one book
here that uh... we should tell our
viewers attention to
if your book that is published today i
believe he is mala i a m again affect
what's a bus the message of this book
uh... do the people of america says
we're told that book mccarthyism leaflet
for america
it is uh...
he carefully documented history of the
fight to expose communists
van security risks
and the dupes who stages of the kremlin
have banned and still are in our federal
government senator yes it is also
distributors i'm sorry that china's at
present
i'm sure that yours is appreciated your
clear forthright views and thank you for
being with us
the editorial board for this additional
amount being promised felt
laws mister william bradford hearing and
mr dot on dot roger
our distinguished guests was the
honorable joseph oligopoly
united state senator from wisconsin
the united states olympic committee has
chosen launching market
to drive all events
for the selection of the united states
olympic team of nineteen fifty two
thanks to the find financial responsible
public
buffalo team representing virtually all
that water sports
will go to helsinki
and the members of the team on selected
through competitive
and to find these events
long gene has provided some one hundred
launching olympic timing watchers
the world's finest timing watch
with accuracy certified by bulletins
from a government observatory
now because of such demonstrated
accuracy
long gene has chosen the time
championship sports events
the world over
the nineteen fifty two olympic winter
games
pan-american games
and the third bought a very
long jane his official watch
for the contest board of the american
automobile association
the american powerboat association
the national aeronautics association and
many many others
because also a lot of the exceptional
trustworthiness
and the accuracy that long gene watches
like these m
there the first choice with
discriminating men and women throughout
the world
long jane the world's most audible
preemie our product of that on jane but
not watch company
since eighteen sixty six
maker of watches all the higher
we invited to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time
watermelon gene pronto
a television journal of the important
data that they are
broadcast on behalf of launching the
world's most on iraq
and what not distinguish companion for
the world on a donkey
reminding you know that long gene and
whatnot watches
console them service from coast to coast
by more than four thousand leading
killer
proudly displayed at them
pages then paul long jean what norwalk